près de 310 mille yvelinois ont repris
le chemin de l'école ce jeudi 2
septembre une nouvelle rentrée dans un
contexte de crise sanitaire pour les
parents pas d'inquiétude particulière
les élèves ont pris l'habitude pas plus
d'inquiétude voire beaucoup moins que
l'an passé les choses sont bien rodés
dans l'école tout s'est très bien
déroulé l'année dernière effectivement
les masques sont toujours là mais on a
l'impression pour les enfants ça change
pas grand chose un peu comme l'année
dernière pour mon fils qui est pas censé
m2 cette année ça s'est très bien passé
comme l'année dernière même moins
stressant parce que du coup valise avait
déjà
connu ça l'année dernière les protocoles
sanitaires diffèrent selon les niveaux
dans le premier degré si malgré le
maintien des gestes barrières et les
précautions prises un enfant est porteur
de l'aco vide la classe est fermée
pendant une semaine dans ces conditions
là le professeur travaillera à distance
avec l'ensemble de la classe lorsqu'on
est au collège ou au lycée
là on procède ce qu'on appelle le
contact racing ce qu'ils ont et donc été
qu'à contacter ces élèves là et
seulement ceux là font l'objet d'une
éviction mais parmi ceux-là ciena qui
sont complètement vaccinés ils peuvent
revenir en classe nouveauté de la
rentrée les opérations de vaccination
envers les collégiens et les lycéens
les établissements scolaires ont été
liés à 84 centres objectif mettre en
oeuvre la vaccination selon deux
modalités soient les élèves se déplace
vers le centre de vaccination ce sera la
majorité des cas soit nous ferons venir
des équipes mobiles des centres éphémère
dans les établissements donc tout cela
est prêt et nous sommes prêts à démarrer
dès cette semaine et le début de la
semaine prochaine sur la vaccination
pour leurs 50 % des élèves yvelinois ont
reçu une dose de vaccin 30 % disposent
d'un schéma vaccinal complet